[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show
before we get started i've gotten this
question from a few viewers and i want
to make sure all of our records are up
to date time there are a couple of apps
that we list when you sign in to our
website as a member for how to best put
in the members only commercial free
audio feed and I've gotten a few emails
from viewers saying those apps have been
updated they don't really work in the
way you describe and some people say
that they're not even really good so I
would love to hear from members and
please email me about this david at
david pakman.com what app are you using
for the commercial-free bonus show let
me know whether it is an app that is on
android or iOS or both i want to hear
from you so that we can update our
recommendations obviously free apps are
preferred I'd rather people not need a
paid app to get that free bonus show and
commercial free show feed in their phone
but get in touch let me know what you
were using if it's paid or free if it's
Android iOS or both and how you like it
and then we'll update our
recommendations for what people are
actually using and what they like david
at david pakman.com so we have Donald
Trump's latest budget proposal coming in
today probably has already been
delivered it is a four point 89 trillion
dollar package it does things that would
not be surprising given Donald Trump's
rhetoric it increases the military
spending budget it cuts domestic
programs it is the last budget of Donald
Trump's first term in office we can hope
it's his last budget ever and it
proposes military spending of 740
billion that's a 0.3 percent increase
non-defense programs would be cut by 5%
it calls for four point six trillion in
deficit reduction four point four
trillion in spending reductions and a 21
percent cut to foreign aid the budget
would balance after 15 years and it has
absolutely no chance of being approved
in Congress so remember the
president's budgets are political
documents the president's budgets are to
my knowledge never actually the what
become the real budgets of the United
States and they are really sort of
posturing in a sense about what it is
that the president would like to do now
my curiosity Pat is if presidents knew
that their budgets would actually become
real budgets would they still make them
as wildly political as they do or would
they actually have to be more reasonable
well I think you get a benefit out of
making the budget political right
because then your base gets to see
exactly what your priorities are where
you want to put money towards I mean I
think they would go about it in exactly
the same way especially when you talk
about like Republicans who used to once
care about deficit and debt or at least
they claim to care about deficit and
debt and now they don't they no longer
seem to care about that stuff with that
stuff out of the way with them not even
considering debt and deficit I mean they
can just make whatever they want out of
this budget and have whatever wish list
I think a lot of Republican supporters
would actually go along with it
one of the wishlist items in the budget
is two trillion dollars in savings from
entitlements including a hundred and
thirty billion in changes to Medicare it
Medicare prescription drug pricing and
by the way also there's two billion in
there for funding the construction of a
wall with Mexico along the southern
border that was remember one of trumps
big promises that he would do it in the
first term obviously it's not going to
happen Trump every once in a while goes
out and says the wall is being built so
I don't know what to make of this I mean
it's a completely immoral budget the
idea that we need to cut social programs
and increase military spending it's
immoral it's not surprising that this is
what Donald Trump is proposing he's not
going to get the majority of this stuff
and now it will be something that
Democrats and Republicans in the House
of Representatives are actually going to
have to debate and put in place and
that's sort of it I mean it's like we
know what to expect from this guy
there's nothing really surprising in it
it's contradictory to things he's
publicly said it includes money for the
things that he's desperate to do but has
failed to do it includes giving more
money to the military despite the fact
that this has actually been one of the
most and
military presidents we've had in a long
time both in terms of his rhetoric
writing off brain injuries as headaches
and all of the things that we've seen
III feel like I'm in a sense
desensitized because it's exactly what I
would expect from the guy yeah and on
the one hand I want to point out that
elections do matter right it's important
that we won back the house in 2018
because that means that this budget is
not going to get passed and nothing that
even looks like this budget is going to
get passed but on the other hand
Democrats have a tendency to cave in and
so who knows maybe this time around
they'll be willing to approve his
spending for the border wall maybe
they'll approve his increase in military
spending because we've seen them be a
little bit amenable towards that in the
past couple years so you know I mean I
think that ultimately we may have
something I know looks like Trump's
budget here but it's also a good call
for him politically to say that he's not
going to at least right now cut Social
Security and Medicare because he's
running up for re-election and if he has
to go up against Bernie Sanders or
someone else who was really on the
progressive left as the Democratic
nominee they're gonna go after him on
that I mean I don't think this isn't the
time for him now to start talking about
cuts to Social Security and Medicare
yeah I don't think Trump gets the border
wall money I think he probably will get
his 0.3 percent increase to military
spending we've seen by and large many
many Democrats willing to go along with
that now what's interesting last last
thing about this budget even Republicans
if they controlled the house wouldn't
pass this budget like that that's the
the reality a lot of the Republicans
that would would be voting on this
budget or will be or would you know
there would be more if they controlled
the house they would recognize that a
lot of the cuts that Trump wants to make
would be very bad for people in their
congressional districts and could be
very bad for their own re-election I
don't even think Republicans pass this
budget if they control the house yeah it
would be like maybe 80% of what we saw
from the Trump edges I guess the best
way to sort of review this would be to
look back at the the first two budgets
that Trump proposed and how those relate
to the budget that we ended up with yes
that would be the best way to sort of
discern that but yeah you're right it's
not gonna be exactly this but we'll just
have to follow up on what eventually
does get passed and what our priorities
are here in this country because they
tend to be quite out of whack
speaking of priorities there is a draft
executive order that has been obtained
by Kathleen migui
who is the editor of the architectural
record which says that the GSA the
General Services Administration which
runs real estate for the executive
branch you know the executive government
the federal government has tons and tons
of buildings they are planning to get
rid of its philosophy for what federal
buildings are supposed to look like
there will be no more contemporary
architects with weird modern courthouses
and quirky designs they are going to
essentially be going back to
neoclassical architecture this is you
know what's so amazing to me about this
is that Donald Trump whenever I see
Trump hotels and you see pictures of
Trump's penthouse apartment and whatever
it looks so gaudy it looks so dated it
looks so horribly out of style and out
of whack and now you have Donald Trump
coming in and wanting to undo the
guidelines that date back to 1962 under
President John F Kennedy for the variety
of designs that are acceptable for
federal buildings Trump now is trying to
weaponize architecture in some way shape
or form here yeah I don't know I feel
about this because to be honest I do
like the the classic Greek style
architecture I like going to Washington
DC and checking out those old federal
buildings I do like how that all looks
and I'm sure they use this sort of
architecture at courthouses and all
sorts of government buildings across the
country but we have plenty of those
already so I feel like the new ones that
we're building we can sort of explore
new architectural designs we've already
seen that happen and I think you know as
long as it all blends together well as
long as you know you know maybe you'll
have to take two buildings next to each
other that are both federal buildings
and they both have completely different
designs but still those can flow
together nicely I don't think I should
make just a blanket rule like banning
that that water and or newer type of
architecture it doesn't make any sense
to me to for me to see an administration
that is already so authoritarian in so
many ways choose to come out and say we
want to go back to a particular type of
design for all federal buildings it's
the type of thing where you hear Kim
must have all buildings with at least 10
foot tall doors and columns and
gargoyles like it's it's not literally
the same thing but because of all the
other authoritarian tendencies that
Donald Trump has I can't help but be
thinking about that yeah and usually we
try to figure out like why are why are
they doing this why does Trump want to
make this decision and usually the
reason is because he's trying to play to
his base but no one's gonna even hear
about this I mean like aside from our
bonus shows audience and like the people
who were check out the articles about
this sort of stuff like no one's going
to know about this and it's the type of
thing that is going to take place like
more in the future because it has to do
with like newer architecture that may
not go up until well after Trump is
president so maybe they're just like
sort of bothered by the new architecture
at a personal level and this is like
Republicans trying to get their way even
though it's not gonna help them
politically like why are they doing I
have no idea but if they are actually
bothered by the way that for example the
Austin courthouse has an ultra-modern
look
we've got people starving in this
country we've got people dying because
they don't have access to health care
give me a break
and I know we can do multiple things at
once but nothing's broken here I don't
know that we need to go around fixing
this ok producer Pat and producer max
did some canvassing in New Hampshire
over the weekend in advance of the
election in the primary election in New
Hampshire tomorrow night for Bernie
Sanders so how did you get pulled into
this what was the process how did it all
work well I've never done anything like
this before and honestly I probably
wouldn't have done it if not for the
debacle that was the Iowa caucus where
it was clear that Bernie Sanders won the
most amount of votes but the media of
course talks about how was a huge win
for Peabody Jed before we've encountered
any votes because he got the you know
completely irrelevant state delegate
equivalents all that stuff just seemed
like another attempt to screw over
Bernie Sanders and it motivated me it
actually motivated a lot of other people
who were volunteering so I took the
Bernie bus up yesterday to New Hampshire
with producer max we were up at 6
o'clock in the morning Wow we were there
to knock on doors walk around the
streets of New Hampshire was not
something that I was very much looking
forward to because that's a you know
it's kind of a strange thing to like
just go to someone's house knock on
their door or try to
politics with them so I was a little bit
apprehensive at first but I eventually
sort of got into a rhythm I don't know
if I would be too excited to do it again
but if the moment called for it I can't
get definitely so explain so so
basically so they take you up on a bus
and then first of all what part of New
Hampshire were you in and then what type
of instructions and materials do they
give you so we went up to Nashua hamp
Nashua New Hampshire which is right on
the border with Massachusetts and then
Tim Robbins the actor who played Andy
Dufresne in Shawshank Redemption he was
known for that role he is a Bernie
supporter and he spoke in front of us
about you know why we need to campaign
for Bernie Sanders why we have to get
out the vote he tried to inspire the 50
or so volunteers that were there and far
as far as like instructions for what to
say they really don't tell you much they
want you to say that you're volunteering
for the Bernie campaign because that
shows some genuine interest rather than
you know just being someone who's like
paid that makes sense but they want you
to sort of like connect with voters at a
personal level they want you to tell
your own Bernie's story so for many
people maybe that's they lost their
health care coverage or they have
$100,000 and student debt it could be a
number of different things so they want
you to really personalize it but I would
imagine that for the average person who
was you know just somewhat into this
stuff who likes Bernie but isn't all
that well-versed in politics it must be
a really hard thing to do and you know
the crazy thing is like when I actually
go out to these houses most the time
people don't answer right you know 80%
of the time people are not answering the
doors but among the people that do
answer sometimes there's interest
sometimes people just want you to leave
sometimes you can kind of glean that
these people are Trump supporters or
maybe they're going for another
candidate but you get all sorts of
strange responses honestly I wonder too
if it's if it's the best campaigning
strategy but I think just even being out
there even you know having people drive
by other roads or any supporters walking
by trying to canvass I think even that
stuff helps with voter turnout so that's
why in the end I was glad I did it do
they give you Bernie paraphernalia so
that you're visually identified as a
Bernie supporter yeah we had stickers we
had literature in our hands so for the
people who didn't answer their doors
they got some literature so you know
that was that was great
but it didn't it didn't honestly seem
all that well here's the thing so I
assumed that we would be assigned a
neighborhood and you know maybe have
like three or four streets and we'd have
yeah right every single house on that
street yeah that we'd have to eat every
single house on that street because you
know every voters important in New
Hampshire they have same-day voter
registrations so why not just go to
every single house and talk to as many
people as you possibly can but they only
wanted us to go to specific houses and
we were using an app for it and maybe we
would go to like one big street and
there would only be three doors that
we'd have to knock on and so you know I
don't know the internals of all this
maybe this is the best campaigning
strategy but to me it seemed as if maybe
it would have been more effective just
to try to reach out to everyone and then
you know sort of log our results from
that the responses that we got from that
but I wonder if the idea is to target
known voters and known Democratic voters
or like yeah I'm curious what the
strategy is and we also noticed that
some of the houses that we went to we
already saw Bernie paraphernalia there
or in one case someone had said like all
the Bernie people already came by twice
so you know I I hope it's not just that
they're having sort of problems with the
operation at large but I think a big
part of the reason why there was there
was so much chaos was that there were
just so many volunteers which is
actually like a blessing in disguise
that's a good problem to have right and
so at first we were only assigned like
2025 doors that was actually we were
first assigned to an apartment complex
which was tough because you have to be
buzzed in or like wait for someone to
come out and you know people aren't
necessarily willing to buzz you in if
they know you're working for a campaign
like they don't want to talk to you in
the first place so that was tricky but
then later we were in like a more of a
suburban area and that was a little bit
more enjoyable got to you know have a
little bit of exercise walking around
the streets of New Hampshire at the very
least and so the transportation just
gets you to Nashua and then you're on
foot the rest of the way no we actually
had a carpool there's a carpool so one
of the other canvassers was driving us
around and dropping off us off in
different locations from that
perspective it was actually organized
very very well and we stopped for lunch
at one point at this nice New Hampshire
cafe I forget the name of it and we saw
we saw a cameraman
off in the corner of the cafe and we
were like oh what is this for he goes oh
it's for PBS there
very cool we start to finish up our
lunch and like clean up the table so
that more people can come in and you
know sit at the table and as I'm getting
up to leave I look over and judy
woodruff s'right there and she asked me
if we're done eating there and I'm like
yes yes we are and I didn't notice
they're quite at that point but later
max told me who it was and I was very
starstruck so she was just looking for a
table to have a sandwich basically
basically yeah it was it was a big
moment in my life I mean tim robbins and
judy woodruff in the same day it was a
starstruck day yeah yeah so definitely
just on that alone definitely worth
going up there I think did you find that
the cafe had plenty of vegan options
plenty of vegan options I was blown away
well I thought yeah yeah I was
definitely blown away and you know maybe
because maybe I just want to I should
probably bring this up to you
I think we had one good story from from
this canvas thing that made it all
worthwhile which was that we went to one
apartment and we ran into a Bernie
supporter who said that he thought it
was too late like he didn't realize that
New Hampshire had same-day registration
and so he thought it was all over he was
a Bernie fan but he didn't think he
would be able to vote and you know just
us showing up there and delivering that
news to him I think we got out the vote
that way so you know I don't know how
many total people we convinced her
brought to our side I don't know if it
was even five people but you know we did
our part we tried at least well listen
if Bernie wins by one you and Max will
single-handedly be responsible for
turning the New Hampshire primary over
to Bernie Sanders which so let's keep
that in our back pocket as we watch the
results come in tomorrow night I hope
you will join me for a results live
stream tomorrow Tuesday night with the
New Hampshire primary results I had been
invited by a group of journalists to go
up to New Hampshire the way we did back
in 2016 and interview voters and there's
a they've rented out like an entire bar
and it's a good setup but I know that I
would not be able to do as good of a
show I wouldn't be able to do audience
participation it would be a mess half
the time the Internet at these things is
very very spotty so I decided I'm gonna
stay stateside literally in the state of
Massachusetts and/or Commonwealth and I
am going to be doing the results live
show on YouTube
which and Facebook live so that'll be
tomorrow night but we've got tomorrow's
show and bonus show coming up long
before that the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]